[Musique]
non
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois le philosophe
jacques rancière l'auteur de la nuit des
prolétaires du maître ignorant de la
haine de la démocratie
pour son nouveau livre les trente
glorieuses qui vient juste de paraître à
la fabrique un recueil d'une trentaine
de textes parus ou prononcé à la radio
au cours des trente dernières années qui
ont le grand mérite d'expliquer
politiquement notre époque bonjour
jacques rancière merci d'avoir accepté
mon invitation
1991 par et c'est la fin de l'histoire
le livre de francis fukuyama qui
annonçait le règne mondiale de la
démocratie libérale la fin des
idéologies et des conflits meurtriers ce
qu'on appela chez nous le consensus
votre livre fait le constat de la
faillite de ces prophéties et pas
seulement parce qu'il ya toujours des
guerres et des fanatiques religieux le
consensus libéral lui même dit vous
s'est retourné en son contraire
oui bon si on reprend les choses un peu
au point de départ quoi bon 89 c'est
l'effondrement du système soviétique et
par conséquent dit en quelque sorte une
espèce de raisonnement fort a contrario
qui dit bon effectivement ce système qui
est qui était fondée sur différents
pouvoirs despotiques a échoué il a
échoué politiquement et économiquement
c'est donc la preuve que liam futur que
ce qui est bien c'est le contraire et le
contraire effectivement on peut
l'appeler de fonds de 2 nous sommes peu
près équivalent à savoir libre marché
démocratie donc à partir de ce moment là
on a cette espèce d'identification entre
will he is on lie au marché ce qui veut
dire en fait au fond
pour existantes la capitalisme qui n'a
plus aucune limite qui n'a plus d'autre
qui n'a plus d'autre finalement et puis
la démocratie autant n'en parla le
régime représentatif qui existe un
certain nombre de 10 ans des pays les
plus riches de la planète donc voilà il
ya eu cette espèce d'identité
notification au départ voilà entre quoi
entre l'idée du triomphe du droit et
l'idée du triomphe d'une puissance qui
est la puissance fait du capital
désormais désormais limités et donc
voilà j'ai j'ai essayé de dire bon que
qu'est ce qui est annoncé sous le faux
sous le mot de triomphe de la démocratie
mondiale à l'époque c'est l'idée
effectivement qu'on a un système qui est
à la fois de plus
parce que gala d'élection libre il ya
tout ça quoi et puis le plus efficace
parce qu'il ya le libre marché et que
bien sûr à partir du moment où on était
au fond juste et efficace tout doit bien
marcher par conséquent non on va vers le
règne monde le règne mondiale au fond
d'un d'un monde apaisé où désormais on
voit puis se battent pour des idéologies
qu'on a bien vu que l'idéologie c'est
fini ça sert à rien ça mène à la ruine
ça m'aide à la dictature et par
conséquent désormais voilà on va se
discuter sur les intérêts communs on va
négocier et tout va s'arranger alors
évidemment bon là on voit bien que ça
n'a pas marché comme ça et bon ski
essayé de suivre c'est effectivement la
logique interne pour dire que c'est pas
simplement le fait que bon bah ya eu des
gens quelque sorte qu'on pas jouer le
jeu du consensus d'ailleurs que très
rapidement il ya eu des guerres
interethniques et une nouvelle guerre
religieuse mais n'est pas que ça vient
de la logique interne de ces systèmes
qui s'est montrée tout autre que ce
qu'on attendait alors justement revenons
il ya trente ans les ya 30 ans c'est
l'effondrement
du communisme c'est la chute de l'urss
mais ça on en parle très souvent ce
qu'on a un peu oublié c'est que c'est
aussi la guerre du golfe il ya trente
ans et la guerre du golfe c'est une
coalition de 26 pays autour des états
unis là on voit les les bombardements de
bagdad à l'époque un tel qu'on pouvait
les voir à la télévision alors une
coalition contre un dictateur saddam
hussein qui a envahi son voisin le
koweït et c'est une guerre que l'on
trouvait à l'époque exemplaires elle
était à la fois légale légitime et
nécessaire
et sur quoi reposait alors ce consensus
que vous vous qualifiez plutôt à
l'époque quand vous écrivez
votre texte vous le qualifiez de
despotisme éclairé oui parce que qu'est
ce qui se passe au moment de la de la
première guerre du golfe c'est qu'on a
effectivement quelque chose comme le une
espèce de vérification à bab seulement
empirique de la logique du consensus bon
il ya un méchant dictateur qui envahit
son voisin mais il n'a pas seulement
envahi son voisin il envahit un pays qui
a bon disons pour papa que ça vaut 3 %
de ressources des ressources disons
pétrolière bien monde pour sans même me
suis forcée voilà donc allé dire à
l'oeil elle toute seule si tous
l'argumentation qui était tout même par
un texte rédigé signé par des
philosophes tout à fait prestigieux qui
dit justement va à la fois où on ne peut
pas laisser un dictateur libre de son
action mais aussi on va pas laisser tant
de temps de pétrole entre les mains d'un
dictateur donc voilà il ya deux buts
cette semaine identification immédiate
en quelque sorte entre bon une question
qui était une question de savoir à qui
appartient le pétrole quoi et puis il ya
la question de la défense de la
démocratie évidemment tout ça a rebondi
lors de la deuxième guerre du golfe
parce qu'à ce moment là disons s'était
pas simplement l'idée de bien d'autres
dictatures mais c'était le vide
d'apporter à dire d'apporter la
démocratie là là où elle n'était pas il
y avait aussi très présents à l'époque
en 90 91 au monde la première guerre du
golfe les l'idée du le respect du droit
international et le respect du droit
c'est quelque chose vous le dit hein
constamment dans vos textes pendant 30
ans ses fondateurs c'est fondamental à
notre époque dans l'idée que l'on se
fait du consensus
oui enfin le respect du droit
international en même temps disons il
est de disons d'emblée en quelque sorte
bon contradictoires contradictoires ce
que bien sûr on va s'insurger contre un
deux contre un état qui viole qui
veulent vous frontières qui est reconnue
est bon et en mai mais en même temps
disons le la lutte contre cette
violation est aussi et dix ans le le
moyen de window d'oublier en quelque
sorte le principe du droit des peuples à
disposer d à disposer d'eux mêmes c'est
à dire que mon très vite fonds
l'expansion de de ce qu'on appelle la
démocratie seuil en fait le système
fonctionnant dans l'est dans l'est dans
les pays riches watts est
sorte de légitimation
nous disons du fait d'oublier notre part
de ce droit international à savoir
l'idée d'une règle du respect du droit
des peuples du droit des peuples à
disposer d'eux mêmes le il ya le 11
septembre
après la après les attentats l'amérique
dit voit accepter d'en faire un combat
du bien contre le mal et est d'ailleurs
la guerre contre le terrorisme qui va en
découler ça va être une espèce de combat
illimité infini du rien contre le mal
mais comment l'amérique ans et elle pu
faire autre chose qu'à combat du bien
contre le mal
il ya ya ya eu il ya une chose dont qui
est disons un attentat bon attentats
terroristes terroriste d'une violence
effectivement
inaperçu inaperçus jusque là quoi d'une
violence effectivement extrême est bon
et abominable quoi aimer heroes est
intéressant c'est que aussitôt en
quelque sorte cette espèce d'attentats
dont on peut dire qu'il était bon
effectivement un attentat profonde à la
puissance dominante la puissance dix ans
qui gouvernait le monde a été
effectivement perçu comme un attentat
contre les valeurs de l'amérique c'est à
dire que immédiatement dans la dans la
réponse aux attentats du 11 septembre et
où cette espèce d'identification d'une
communauté américaine qui n'est pas
simplement bon un état justement régi
par les règles de l'état de droit par le
respect des libertés moyens si de suite
mais qu'était un état qui était comme
une espèce de vraiment de malades de
fraternité de manière de lait d'une
manière de vivre ou justement encore une
fois le fond y avait comme ce père gay
d'identité entre un certain type de
d'économie achat d'un type de régime
politique est vraiment une manière de
vivre bon c'est ça en quelques cents ce
qui a été considéré comme le bien du
temps voilà il ya eu dès le lendemain
fait il des doigts le tacle attaques
contre l'amérique c'était faux au fond
de quoi c'était quelque chose comme
comme l' attaque contre les principes
mêmes de fondeurs des états unis une
particulier bombe a contredit au fond la
recherche du bonheur quoi s'inquiéter de
recommencer un des principes un des
principes fondateurs donc au fond il y
avait eu lieu aussitôt ce d'espèces de
traduction en termes moraux terme en
termes moraux bien sûr plusieurs
intervenants avaient quand même leur
rôle à jouer dans la ferrière quoi mais
en même temps dit ça devenait une
partition du mondial le monde vu bien le
monde du bien et et le monde du malt et
effectivement il ya eu cet appel en
quelque sorte une fois de plus au fond à
identifier les puissances économiques
les plus fortes du monde une partie
d'entre elles une bonne partie de
retrait en tout cas à disons le le camp
la démocratie et le camp du bien en
lutte contre le contre l' empire du mal
alors bon évidemment bien sûr en europe
on se moque un peu de sens visant les
grecs font un peu ils sont un peu en
arrière avec toi mais d'une certaine
façon c'était pareil j'ai été avancée
d'une certaine façon rue parce qu'on a
fait la même chose nous après les
attentats du 13 novembre notamment on a
dit aussi qu'on s'en prenait à notre
manière de vivre vous auriez voulu qu'en
fait ils vous auriez trouvé plus normal
plus logique qu'ils en fassent et nous
aussi par la même occasion un combat
politique est pas un combat éthique ou
religieux
bon je dire que les dimensions sont
toujours effectivement mêlée mais fonda
fondamentalement il ya eu il ya eu cette
manière fond de soude et de souder un
peu bon un pays une nation qui par
ailleurs est une nation divisée comme
tout est comme toutes les nations comme
tout comme tous les peuples pu dire
moderne quoi en même temps de refaire
comme une espèce de blocs de blocs
absolument inentamable on avoue ça aussi
effectivement bon après après les
attentats en france quoi et puis bon
c'est quelque chose qu'un timbre cccd
fait très très rapidement parce qu'il ya
quelque chose fectivement bond de
l'arctique est ce encore une fois bon on
est en affaires à des attentats qui sont
absolument monstrueux mais mais on met
en même temps je dirais qu'il ya une
espèce de réponse qui est brute d'être
dit au fond de la mer une réponse de
qu'on pourrait dire deux armes disons
armes contre armes une certaine façon
pas
dix ans est devenu effectivement le
comme le combat contre toute une manière
de vivre et hugues bon il ya 8 août ces
identifications que des fêtes après
retrait effectivement la république la
laïcité voilà je crois que le fond du
problème dans l'idée du consensus c'est
qu'au fond là on constitue recul une
communauté comme unis vraiment unis par
le lieu où elle est unie par sa
provenance par son histoire par ses
passes et par ses valeurs vedettes du
même coup ben forcément disons on est en
face de l'autre absolue
c'est la logique du consensus au fond
c'est la fin de la politique oui enfin
bon en tout cas la logique du consensus
c'est savent peut-être pas
d'identification de fonds a pris un peu
de tout quoi savoir 2 da régime
économique d'un système d'un système
institutionnel d'un ensemble d'un
ensemble de valeurs partagées bon voilà
ou alors à partir du moment où il ya
quelque chose qui coince est bon et qui
coince bon sens c'est un euphémisme bien
sûr où il ya quelque chose disons
quelques atouts qui naquit le banquier
qui rencontre était encore temps de
résistance qui a rencontré bon une
altérité aussi aussitôt on est dans
quelque chose comme falla l'affrontement
absolue la fonte pape ce lieu voilà il
brouille a effectivement tu vois cette
tendance qui bien sûr a été favorisée
par les islamistes même et bien sûr mais
qu'a t on quelques entreprises au fond
cette idée de l'opposition de monde un
monde et on a vu se constituer après les
attentats du 11 septembre avec
l'invasion de la guette l'afghanistan
puis l'invasion de l'irak en 2003 une
sorte de droit absolu dites-vous
illimitée
extra juridique de la victime en
l'occurrence et l amérique et
la victime d'un mal infini le mot
infinie d'ailleurs aux rennais justice
infinie et
la puissance est militaire américaine
qu'on voit là tout à coup devenu une
puissance judiciaire
oui
il ya eu ça effectivement dans l'idée de
justice infinie bonté du roi george bush
junior qui a lancé le mot pour après ça
il a dit l'un pour cet été un peu
corrigé la ville un peu bon il a un peu
exagéré mais voilà il y avait sept pieds
cette idée peu d'eau font que ya un
droit de la victime qui est un droit
absolu quoi et je pensais que ce qui est
intéressant parce que au fond c'est le
droit des victimes comme droit absolu
bon c'était d'abord le ils ont le droit
des peuples bon imprimé est bon il y
avait l'idée que les grandes puissances
devaient eux se devait de venir en aide
aux peuples opprimés bon il ya eu ça qui
était en jeu au moment des conflits et
des conflit interethnique dans l'ex dans
l'ex yougoslavie
cette fac s'est mis en jeu mais nos très
rapidement ce droite de la victime est
devenu le droit de celui qui défend la
victime est bien sûr faux le droit du
défenseur lui-même c'est-à-dire que il
ya eu ce jeu à se hisser
à croire incroyable ou oui effectivement
la victime est posée comme victime d'un
thorax du parti d'un moment il ya un
tort absolue ça veut dire que la
personne du docteur est elle même
abstenue ça veut dire qu'il ya au fond
une espèce de de droits droits des
victimes sauf que la victime en général
peut pas exercer ce droit par conséquent
il faut qu'il y ait quelqu'un et puis
quelqu'un donc une puissance qui
exercent ce droit pour la victime et
qu'il exerce effectivement au nom de ce
tort absolue et bien sûr ça veut dire
qu'il n'existe absolument ça va avec
brodé avec des armes et qui ne
connaissent plus aucune forme de limite
à deux limitations et au fond on va au
cours de ces trente années que vous
décrivez que vous commentez plus
exactement dans ce livre on va
progressivement effacées au fond les
frontières du droit au nom du droit on
va finir par effacer les frontières du
droit oui parce qu'il ya cette sorte d
d'identification absolue entre eux entre
le droit et le fait que c'est ça c'est
vraiment le coeur le corps du consensus
à l'époque de la guerre du vietnam
voilà il y avait quelque sorte une
espèce de querelle sur le droit le crâne
sur le droit c'est à dire que bon il y
avait donc tous les 10 longs la jeunesse
la jeunesse américaine remond révolter
contre contre la guerre
tout mouvement reprend la guerre qui
opposait les principes justement
fondateurs des états unis un petit a le
droit des peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes
qu'ils au point quelques bancs question
qui oppose et ça à la guerre eux mené
comme les états unis donc au fond on
était là à cette époque qui ont parlé
encore d'impérialisme en a un peu
disparu depuis quoi on était à cette
époque où au fond le que la querelle
politique s'emparait de l'écart entre
les fonds la manière dont on est apte
définissez et puis sa pratique effective
or justement à brandir tape atteint le
11 septembre
ça m'a tout ça tout ça disparaît on peut
ça disparaît à savoir qu'il ya
évidemment une affirmation qui a aucun
cas aucun écart qui est c'est ça
effectivement que tu avais un peu
commenté à l'époque un manifeste un
certain nombre d'intellectuels américain
qui est vrai qu'il disait bon voilà le
détail ni c'est d'abord c'est d'abord au
fond une collectivité qui est unie par
un ensemble de valeurs éthiques de basse
quoi et appartient à ce moment là il ya
plus des cas on peut proposer on va
pouvoir poser la guerre la guerre
violente on peut plus opposée à
l'invasion de deux territoires de
territoire qui en principe inquiétants
avaient leur liberté on peut plus
opposer sa aux principes fondateurs de
la nation américaine non c'est devenu en
quelque sorte dont la même chose il
yad'ailleurs l'illusion du consensus au
moment de 2 alors des attentats du 11
septembre indéniablement les mêmes de
l'invasion de l'irak qui a pas
d'opposition aux états unis cette
invasion comme il existait une
opposition réelle importante à la guerre
du vietnam au fola il ya tout à coup un
consensus américain dont on peut dire
quelques années plus tard qu'il est
totalement volé en éclats puisqu'on l'a
vu avec à la fin du du règne de donald
trump et avec l'invasion du capitole on
le dit aujourd'hui l'amérique n'a jamais
été autant divisée donc c'est un échec
ouais enfin oui pour moi pour moi il ya
ben y'a pas vendredi gens-là l'invasion
de capitol effectivement c'est en
quelque sorte le mans vont
l'accomplissement fond de la logique du
consensus va effectivement se retourne
en se retournant quoi se retournant
contre elles mêmes à savoir bon
finalement
ya une paix de logique qui est qui part
du fait que au fond il ya une sorte
d'identification absolu du droit du
droit et du fait qu'ils aient soutenu
effectivement il ya des grandes
campagnes militaires des états unis et
qui au fond précisément fois a fini par
ne plus tenir compte une certaine
logique bon institutionnels bon
jusqu'ici aux états unis bon en général
voient la brouille avec même une règle
d'une règle du jeu c'était quelquefois
un peu un peu difficile ça veut dire ça
a été ça avait déjà été un problème
disons bon en 2004 lors de la réélection
si réélection il ya eu une vraie mort de
deux bouts choix mais n'ont pas eu tort
en 2000 c'est c'est en
2004 il est réélu les tracks septembre à
décembre 2000 au moins au moment des
élections donc il y avait eu déjà un peu
cette espèce de deux bombes ils ont
malgré tout deux
épisodes ou aux fonds qu'elles viendront
donner ou la cour suprême dit bon ça y
est bon il a gagné pilpa poitrinal quoi
bon ce qu'on a connu il vient bien sûr
en 2000 en 2020 est complètement est
complètement différent mais justement au
fond il ya ces kids écueil au fond il ya
une puissance il ya un pouvoir qui
incarne l'amérique et que par rapport à
ça bon finalement l'homme le jeu
institutionnel bon finalement c'est pas
si important que ça je crois que voilà
je viens bien moment où cette espèce
d'identification co éthique consensuelle
de la communauté fait que les règles
normales disons comme ça du jeu
politique bon ben on peut on peut être
en ce groupe et transgresser près
transgresser parce que la vraie amérique
et brûlé par mill road on déclare
qu'elle est parmi les gens cambistes le
capitole et pas disons pas parmi les
gens qui ont voté contre un alors il ya
trente ans on l'a dit c'est
l'effondrement de l'urss et du
communisme qui sont saluées chez nous
comme comme au fond des la liquidation
des utopies
c'est on va devoir adhérer au cours
nécessaires des choses c'est comme ça
que vous l'analysez 1 dans les trente
glorieuses et on peut prendre l'exemple
vous le prenez d'ailleurs deux des
grèves de 95 donc entre la réforme des
retraites dieu c'est sûr mais il ya eu
des réformes des projets de réforme des
retraites et dieu sait s'il ya eu des
protestations régulière donc là on se
souvient tous de celle ci en 95 et c'est
là que au fond va naître l'idée d'un
certaine archaïsme des classes
populaires notamment des ouvriers qui ne
veulent pas comprendre le monde tel
qu'il est en réalité
winos toronto ce qui est intéressant
c'est que bon cette idée de la nécessité
historique et du et des gens qui
réussissent à la nécessité s'était
d'abord malgré tout le marxisme qui
l'avait qu'il a grenoble on a été la
gloire de dire le sens de l'histoire le
centre de leusse en ce sens de
l'histoire et un petit peu la
déréliction de ces petits bourgeois le
s'éclate l'archaïque qui s'accrochent
comme ça un monde qui dit qui est
désormais révolu alors que font la
marche un marché réputé alliez me
prépare la marche du socialisme est donc
finalement et progressistes à sa manière
cette logique de la nécessité historique
bon il se trouve que un modèle a été
elle a été reprise une reprise de
produire de l'autre côté c'est à dire
que un caprice précisément pour
s'opposer à toutes les formes de
mouvements de mouvements sociaux est
effectivement 95 a été un moment
intéressant parce que on a vu justement
toute une partie de l'intelligentsia de
gauche tout d'un coup bas découvrir que
là il y avait une nécessité économique
qui conditionnait la vie de la commune
de notre communauté et qu'il y avait
malheureusement d un peu d arriérés
comme ça qui tenait leur système de
retraite à leurs privilèges archaïque
prague il ya eu ce moment pour ça ça a
commencé c'est déjà avec ce mot commence
après ce livre qui s'appelait jetez plus
et qui dit
d'un journaliste tim sacs contre les
privilégiés des privilégiés vallée
c'étaient les cheminots les vues des
privilégiés bassett s'était finalement
les gens qui jouissait
des droits sociaux qui avait été acquis
par des décennies de luttes sociales
quoi il ya eu effectivement ce moment
très fort de 82 95 ou bon ça a été la
première grande grande offensive je sais
qu'elle a eu plusieurs vagues
l'offensive 2 ne ment pas disons de
notre pouvoir pour comment commencer à
en finir avec lui son va tout et pour
tout ce système de protection de
solidarité sociale et retraite de tout
ce à quoi est bon et ce qui est
intéressant c'est ce mot ce moment qui a
été un moment de route de grand
retournement idéologique qui a marqué
bon ce que j'ai appris à la contre
révolution intellectuelle quoi tu es ou
effectivement au fond là la logique a
été celle de la gauche d'une certaine
gauche à savoir qu'il faut être dans le
sens de l'histoire se retrouver pris
dans le dos de l'autre côté bon il faut
être dans le sens de l'histoire le sens
de l'histoire c'était plus c'était plus
la marche de la révolution
c'était c'était la nécessité économique
de reproduction bon indéfinie du marché
capitaliste mais là ça n'est que le
début en 95 on va avoir d'autres on a eu
récemment encore en
2019 la même enfin une autre réforme des
retraites qui a donné à peu près les
mêmes images d'ailleurs j'aimerais que
cela soit en 2019 et puis va y avoir
juste après les gilet jaune notre
mouvement qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui se
passe à chaque fois c'est contre là
c'est vous laissez entendre qu'au fond
ce que veut le pouvoir depuis 30 ans
c'est un mettre fin aux solidarités oui
le mot il ya dix ans aux grands thèmes
qu'on met en avant à savoir on veut en
sortir avec le monde le monde les gens
sont assistés on veut en finir à clay
avait état providence et des espèces de
systèmes finalement paternaliste mais en
réalité c'est un peu tout le contraire
c'est ce qui est bien ce qui me aba
petit à petit c'est pas ce qu'on
appelait état providence qui est mis à
bas c'est tout un système de de
solidarité sociale qui fonctionnait
aussi à partir de là disons de la preuve
de la présence dans le dans le jeu même
des discussions des négociations de tout
doute une partie bon de la classe
ouvrière tout une partie finalement des
syndicats pendant et travailleur voilà
donc au fond soit soi-disant soi-disant
audio là on va en finir avec l'état
providence comme ça qu'ils qui couvre
comme ça tous les individus mais c'est
en réalité le contraire ce que ce qu'on
installe petit à petit c'est le rapport
direct au fond de deux puissances aux
individus dont la puissance du libre
marché c'est à dire du capitalisme
absolutiser et puis la puissance de
l'état avait en face de quoi il n'y a
plus que des individus isolés donc sous
prétexte de démolir l'état providence on
installe au contraire faut un état qui
se déclarent seul responsable de tout ce
qui peut nous arriver à tous et il ya
aussi avec 95 et on le voit et pour
finir avec les jets les jaunes il ya on
donne une un visage une forme à ce qu'on
a appelé le populisme tout à coup tout
ces gens
tousser gilet jaune on va les qualifié
de populiste
oui bon qualifie au qualifient de
populiste vont maintenant en gros tout
ce qui sauve tout ce qui s'oppose à la
logique consensuelle quoi est bon ça
veut dire éventuellement des choses
complètement différentes et des gens
l'ont le voyant 95 95
les cheminots et les tous les
travailleurs des transports en grève ont
été qualifié de populiste parce qu'ils
étaient à redouter sur leurs privilèges
leurs petits intérêts personnels et
voilà allez à l'époque il ya des
intellectuels distinguer qui ont dit bon
finalement c'est à peu près la même
chose que le front national bon blague
ici s'arc boute sur leur identité
ouvrière leurs privilèges ouvriers comme
d'autres s'arc boute sur l'idée de
l'unité nationale et la cct ce moment
quelque sorte mon ami ensemble de choses
à savoir d'un côté les l'effort pour
maintenir un monde de solidarité
collective roues ou pire les gens
participent eux-mêmes quoi et puis et
puis ils ont les idées racistes
xénophobes et anti immigrés bon et ainsi
de suite quoi fond le concept de
populisme a servi à mettre à mettre tout
ça on va mettre ça ensemble quoi pas du
côté du stand une espèce de 2 me de
marécages un peu de jambes à rire est
quoi mais là aussi au fond c'est u11
d'échec du consensus parce que le
consensus dont on rêvait d'une nouvelle
les classes dirigeantes
il incluait les les ouvriers les classes
populaires
il y avait l'idée du ruissellement il y
avait l'idée de on allait réussir tous
ensemble tout ça c'est un échec non mais
je crois pas parce que le consensus se
construit c'est pas dit qu'on va être
monde doit être d'accord le consensus
c'est l'idée qu'on peut pas ne pas être
d'accord parce qu'il ya une nécessité
que objective et par conséquent bon bah
bah on va on va affronter cet été cités
ça veut dire bon les gens compétents que
pour affronter parce que tout le monde
peut pas affronter de la nécessité
equateur ça marche pas ça c'est quand
voilà le consensus c'est d'abord le
consensus mou des élites
gouvernementales
des puissances financières et puis bon
des experts médias dominants pour dire
qu'il ya une seule réalité est que ya
une seule chose à faire on va faire une
pause jacques rancière on se retrouve
juste après d'accord
[Musique]
comme à chaque début d'année olivier
vous nous livrer vos scénarios pour les
365 jours à venir il ya beaucoup de pire
pas beaucoup de bons scénarios clésud la
présidentielle et son impact sur
l'économie il n'y a pas de grande
révolution à attendre un grand
changement par rapport à ce qui a été
comme politique on passe au prix de
l'énergie ça plombe la reprise
économique est malheureusement ce n'est
pas quelque chose qui se qui se règlent
en deux minutes si vous voulez par
l'opération du saint-esprit le dernier
règle de la politique monétaire des
banques centrales c'est la banque
centrale qui soutient à bout de bras
tout l'édifice si jamais elle arrête à
ce moment là tout s'écroule comment on
va pouvoir se défaire de ça c'est la
question la plus la plus problématique
et on voit bien que on arrive à un
moment où on lâche tout
[Musique]
en 2010 il y avait environ 200
satellites en orbite en 2021 on en
compte quatre mille et en 2030 il y en
aura plus de 100 milles autour de la
terre le secteur spatial est un domaine
stratégique
où les plus grandes puissances se
livrent une guerre économique
territoriale et militaire essentiel de
l'aventuré c'est pas tellement laventure
scientifique mais c'est d'abord une
recherche de supériorité stratégique
rien n'est simple car les intérêts sont
divergents et la concurrence totale
[Musique]
voilà de retour avec le philosophe
jacques rancière qui publie les trente
glorieuses
aux éditions la fabrique donc c'est
pendant ces trente dernières années vous
avez commenté quasiment en direct dans
des textes publiés ou lu à la radio
écrit au moment même où se déroulaient
les événements en même temps qu'ils
avaient sur la scène internationale ce
que nous avons décrit en même temps
qu'il y avait sept ce rapport aux
classes populaires
que danton dont on a parlé on va prendre
également à septembre de mesures qui
sous couvert d'otéra l'extrême droite à
l'époque uniquement représentée par jean
marie le pen son cheval de bataille en
fait on va renforcer continûment la
figure de l'autre de l'étranger de
l'immigré
inassimilable
[Rires]
on peut dire que le moment le moment clé
dont vous parlez c'est la loi contre le
voile à l'école
oui contre le voile à l'école c'est à
dire en fait c'est contre le foulard en
fait le vans le mot même de voile
précisément été en quelque sorte bon
instaurait pour pouvoir confondre un
petit peu des choses quand même bon
assez différente parce qu'on peut avoir
un foulard autour de la tête et avoir
une burqa qui vous cache entièrement
c'est pas catalan la même chose mais peu
un peu un peu importe oui moi ce qui est
ce qui me paraît aussi significative
pensez il ya eu ce moment pas si on
parle de ces lois où
il ya eu quelque chose comme une au
fonds de contributions bain de gauche
républicaine laïque à quelque chose qui
était bon jusque là porté par l'extrême
droite à savoir bon là le refus de
l'immigré la désignation d'une
population une population comme disons
pas une assise inassimilable quoi est il
ya eu bon ce moment at il seulement à
c'est pas bon ça s'est fait petit à
petit parce que d'abord il ya eu bon là
l'idée que l'extrême droite pose un vrai
problème immigration c'est un vrai
problème dont elle le traitait mal c'est
quand même un vrai problème d'autres
failles et les résoudre donc il ya eu ce
moment où on a cherché à la fois bon à
discréditer l'extrême droite ils ont vu
sont vraiment pas présentables c'est
encore une fois des bas des gens du
petit peuple un peu arriérés bon un
petit bouton mais il pose un vrai
problème l'immigration on va prendre des
mesures donc on a commencé à prendre des
mesures restrictives les mesures qu'on
peut dire des mesures racistes mais pour
empêcher le racisme avec l'idée que bon
il ya du racisme parce que les immigrés
et que bon si on prétend prend des
mesures pour limiter l'immigration dont
va forcément viendra si ça a été le
premier temps quelque sorte et puis ce
deuxième temps il ya eu un rapport
disons une spectre en fort rebond un peu
un peu inattendu en tout cas où tout
d'un coup c'est voilà la gauche la
gauche républicaine qui au nom de la
grande de la grande tradition de la
république française de la laïcité de
l'égalité des hommes et des femmes à
trouver que cette population était au
fond inassimilable alors qu'il ya des
milliers de manières eux de manière
forte quoi en
on s'en prenant à s'en prenant à ses
moeurs on se reprendre en ça prouve en
s'en prenant à une manière de s'habiller
qui a renvoyé à ses traditions et moi
qui ai aussitôt dénoncé comme guillaume
d'atteinte à la laïcité républicaine
donc élu ce moment je crois très très
fort très fort tout d'un coup la faune
l'extrême droite traditionnelle n'était
plus seule il y avait encore une fois
c'est un peu une sorte de consensus avec
toujours cette logique du consensus à
savoir que voilà nous sommes une nation
qui annonçant qu'un histoire partagée à
l'ensemble des valeurs partagées et puis
il ya des gens qui arrivent d'ailleurs
qui sont qui n'ont pas assimilé alors il
faudra qu'ils assimilent où il faudra
qu'ils assimilent où ça va mal ça va mal
se passer quoi placer il ya sept jours
je crois cette logique du consensus qui
se passe qui se déplace et qui encore
une fois bon fond il reprise par toute
une opinion de gauche qui de même qu'il
avait découvert que les ouvres que les
ouvriers terme en un peu trop archaïque
et égoïste bon découvert que après tout
ces immigrés ils sont musulmans les
musulmans c'est des gens qui voient le
les femmes c'est des gens contre
l'égalité des gens contre leur cédions
votre laïcité que par conséquent c'est
bon c'est pas assimilable ou alors il
faut complet qui change complètement
leur manière de faire et des manières
d'être et au fossat fini dites-vous par
faire du militant antiraciste
du militant anticapitaliste et du tueur
intégristes une seule et même figure
celle de l'islam aux gauchistes
oui bon je le terme d' islamo gauchiste
bond a été
inventé un petit peu de au départ bon
essentiellement pour pour être actif un
peu limité à savoir pour bon faut
assimiler assimilés dont les gauchistes
à dire ceci est essentiellement ceux qui
se battent et impôts pour les droits du
peuple palestinien pour l'épauler pour
les identifier les identifier pour les
identifier pas qu'il m'envoie un fonds
ad à des descendants du nazisme des
descendants passe à deux dixièmes
totalitaire ça a été d'abord ont été
inventés pour ça qu'après effectivement
ça a été ça a été élargi et c'était ce
qui était très intéressant au moment de
la loi donc alloué loi sur le voile donc
qui en principe peut être une loi qui
concerné la burqa pour toujours au nom
des motifs nomme de défendre les femmes
contre ceux qui les oppriment quoi bon
on a inventé 7,7 cette idée c'est le
principe république est absolument
inédit qu'on n'avait pas le droit d'être
masqué dans l'espace publiquement je le
fais rire maintenant j'espère maintenant
vu l'évolution des choses mais voilà
tout d'un coup on a inventé ça ça veut
dire que baldizon la femme qui portait
la burqa et puis le militant et le
militant qui porte un et qui porte un
foulard à la fois pour ceux masqués
aussi pour contre les gaz contre les gaz
lacrymogènes dans une attestation bac
c'est la même chose quoi voilà il ya
tout d'un coup la république ça veut
dire qu'on doit avoir le visage nu quoi
il ya même eu un moment donné où il ya
un polémiste qui s'est mis en colère
parce à cause de l'interdiction du
string al assad ont qu à paris plages
c'est le triomphe de l'islamisme quoi
oui c'est donc il ya eu cette espèce de
de conjonctions où on pour justifier une
mesure qui concernait une fraction de la
population musulmane on a inventé ce
principe qui en même temps fait que pour
s'appliquer à n'importe qui brandt que
tout d'un coup il faut être il faut voir
le visage du dans l'espace public
appartient
le militant le militant antiraciste
et puis le tueur islamistes devenait
devenait une seule une seule figure donc
bon ce que nos ministres ont rappelé
l'islamo gauchisme en 1997 dans le monde
parce que libération l'avait refusée
vous avez écrit un texte qui avait eu un
certain retentissement dans lequel vous
listiers les règles pour aider à la
diffusion des idées racistes en france
et quand on les énumérer ses règles en
force c'était tout ce que faisaient
l'antiracisme depuis le début des années
80 depuis l'apparition du phénomène le
jean marie le pen qui était devenu
ensuite un front national qui ne cessait
de monter dans les élections elle
souhaite racisme etc etc quand vous
disiez par exemple c'était la première
règle relever quotidiennement les propos
racistes et donnez leur un maximum de
publicité c'est ce que faisait
absolument tous les intellectuels et
tous les militants antiracistes à
l'époque où est ce que faisait aussi les
politiciens jusqu'au buzzer aussi les
politiciens aient compris les
politiciens de droite qui à l'époque
quand il faut être respectable et ami
disons et marquer ses distances avec ces
gens là quoi oui c'est est bon c'est
être traité quelque chose de très très
large à savoir on dénonce tous les jours
tous les jours tous les jours bon et
bien sûr le résultat de cette
dénonciation quotidienne c'est que tu es
que continuellement ses idées racistes
était sur le devant de la scène on les
commenter et comme bien sûr on les
commandes pour les biens sûr même temps
pour les pour les dénigrent eps bat pour
attirer la route dessus ça veut dire
quoi que en même temps bon on diffusait
sans arrêt ses idées sous prétexte de
les dénoncer mais qu'en même temps leurs
délégations quelque chose comme comme la
palme du mathieu du martyr qualcomm là
parce qu'à l'époque on l'est on
condamner systématiquement oui on traîne
est même parfois en prison et est au
fond vous dites qu'on installait une
vision du monde là en le faisant sans
doute inconsciemment d'ailleurs parce
qu'il n'était pas conscient je sais pas
si je sais pas si on peut parler de quoi
d'être conscient pas conscient wynn
holmes le problème si vous les bons il
sait que will i am et il ya sept courses
cette idée que
pour combattre quelque chose il faut le
dénoncer pour le dénoncer et on prend
des airs indignés avec l'idée que
bastion option s'indigne sabah montre à
quel point cette chose mais elle est
horrible et puis cette chose-là va
disparaître manon toute façon ça ne
fonctionne pas comme ça c'est un peu le
contraire tant que tant qu'on dénonce
avec des dix honte et grands venez
l'éclat tu vois les idées racistes et
xénophobes
qu'est-ce qu'on fait branler oui en fait
on les dit on n'arrête pas on n'arrête
pas de les diffuser de leur donner de
leur donner de l'importance et elles
sont et en même temps deux tours de
justifier des murs ont des démêlés
mesure d'un madame d'un racisme froid
raisonnable black et yvon sont censés
dillon s'opposer à ça le résultat c'est
pas simplement qu'il y à fond ses idées
se diffuse de plus en plus c'est que
vous de ces petits faits de
contamination
2 bat de la classe de la caste
politicienne de la classe intellectuelle
par ses idées oui et justement ce qu on
a pu constater c'est que non seulement
ces fameuses règles que jamais dicté
effectivement que et qui ont continué à
être suivis de manière absolument
impeccable non pas simplement renforcer
continuellement l'extrême droite en tant
que force politique organisée mais aussi
renforcer considérablement son emprise
fonds sur l'ensemble du pont de la
classe dominante 3-5 c'est comme ça
qu'est qui est frappant qui est frappant
aujourd'hui cauet qui est frappant donne
notamment dans l'actuelle campagne à
savoir que bon des idées qui était
considéré comme brawn des idées bonnes
pour des pubs pour des gens de campagne
un peu arriérés pour des ouvriers qui
avaient perdu leur travail pour des
chômeurs pour des gens vivent de
l'assistance ou que sais-je pour des
gens un peu vos marges quoi maintenant
ce sont les idées qui sont dit qu'ils
sont diffusés moisissure est sûre elle
adore les milliers dans les milieux dans
les milieux chiffon comme en même temps
qu'on faisait des martyrs comme on dit
c'est à dire que certains étaient
effectivement condamné condamner
certains même aller en prison on vous a
des martyrs en même temps on répétait
qu'il y avait bien un problème est que
au fond il fallait régler ce problème si
on voulait en rien le racisme et que le
meilleur moyen d'enrayer de régler ce
problème au fond c'était de faire des
lois des lois qui limitait le nombre
d'immigrés qui interdisait de plus en
plus le racisme mêmes qui essayait de
trouver les moyens d'empêcher les
candidats dits raciste de pouvoir se
présenter aux élections où c'est
effectivement cité parmi les règles que
j'avais rappelé le l'avait rappelée à
l'époque c'est à dire que oui on ya vu
c'était là cette proposition de faire
d'un vent d'inventer finalement des
réformes du code électoral pour kljestan
droite puissent pas avoir de
représentant de représentant un coq à
l'assemblée nationale on en a encore
aujourd'hui tous les jours des
propositions de ce type chasse je ne
suis que je ne suis pas mais voilà je te
dire qu'au fond il ya toujours cette
idée qu'il faut faire il faut prendre
des mesures d'exception qu'est qu'il
faut prendre des mesures qui font qu'ils
limitent qui limite la liberté pour la
défense de liberté bien sûr et donc
demandé de nouvelles lois antiracistes
etc etc
c'est aujourd'hui vous pensez que alors
qui a gagné aujourd'hui puisque vous le
dites ces idées là il était violemment
ou en tout cas qu'on faisait violemment
on était censé violemment combattre à
l'époque
se sont diffusées un peu partout sur
totalement admise
qui a gagné
ce qui a gagné c'est manifestement
l'idéologie de l'extrême droite ce
qu'être ce qui a gagné c'est l'idéologie
de l'exclusion qui était reprise relayé
maintenant devenu effectivement une
idéologie chic quoi bon le passage le
passage de de la famille le pen avait à
zemmour sur une villa est significatif
c'est à dire que la cc c'est plus un
racisme supposé comme ça populaire c'est
vraiment le bois le racisme d'un certain
nombre de voix là de deux journaux de
journaux bien pensants delà de la droite
qui dans le temps se déclaraient libéral
c'est en gros il ya une espèce de
mélange en quelque sorte où le fond
c'est s'il est au fond le mépris le
mépris fondamental de tous ces gens qui
pensent faire partie de l'élite pour une
plaie marierai fo a repris d'une
certaine façon les idées de cette
fameuse plèbe supposé arriérés voilà il
ya ses pets de conjonction entre voilà
une espèce de deux vieux fond raciste et
xénophobe et xénophobe avec ouï dire le
mépris fondamental de gens qui pensent
qu'ils sont seuls qui sont les seuls à
comprendre l'évolution du monde et seul
à comprendre ce qu'il faut faire
les seuls qui doivent diriger les
affaires mais vous n'y voyez que du
racisme vous ne pouvez pas imaginer
qu'il puisse y avoir autre chose à la
fois une panique identitaire qui peut se
comprendre une méfiance à l'égard d'une
religion considérée comme intolérante
plus violente que les autres aussi un
souci à les gardes du traitement des
femmes non pas dans toutes les franges
de la population musulmane mais chez les
plus intégristes tout ça ne peut se
justifier en rien vos yeux il faut dire
que toutes sortes de toutes sortes de
réactions de crainte bon c'est juste ici
bon je dirais que
voilà des problèmes des problèmes dans
la banlieue il y en a eu il y en a eu
d'ailleurs ha bon dix attentats des
attentats bon islamistes non violent
meurtrier bon bon il y en a eu il y en a
eu un certain nombre d'ong oui voilà la
question est de savoir si on règle si on
règle finalement ça avec ce fond c'est
ce type de fonds des usages de la loi
qu'est ce qui est un peu qu est ce qu
est un peu significatif aussi la logique
du consensus c'est qu'on fait un usage
qui est essentiellement bon idéologique
de la loi si on prend donc bon elle a
fallu l'ensemble des l'ensemble des
mesures qu'on a prises l'année dernière
à l'égard de la communauté musulmane
fait un plus auquel titre seconde
séparatisme valoir que la voix contre le
séparatisme mois bon donc entre ses
partisans 906 l'absurdité parce que une
voie à contresens pour les gens qui les
tice s écarte de la loi commune ça n'a
pas de sens mais on voit bien que ces
lois finalement bon ok qu'est ce qu'elle
fait et efficacité sera réellement
coisia re bon on a affaire mon affaire
ben yahia ya des des tueurs il ya des
tueurs il ya des réseaux il ya des
réseaux extrémistes pour qu'ils
favorisent qui favorise les tueurs c'est
un fait quoi bon mais en quoi des
mesures interdisant aux gens de d'élever
leurs enfants d'el dia d'éduquer leurs
enfants à domicile vont agir répondre
vont agir qu'on doit la contre bon
évidemment pas mais ceux ci commencent à
cet ensemble de vous voit que qu'on a
prises sont clairement des lois qui font
constitue d'abord moi toujours la figure
de l'autre de l'autre inassimilable here
bon là oui là où il faudrait essayer de
secourir de sérier les questions
c'est-à-dire de cibler de cibler
véritablement les phénomènes qui sont
dangereux pour les les gens les groupes
qui sont redoutables ont fait exactement
le contraire on prend des espèces de loi
qu dont la fonction est d'abord de
constituer oui toujours là la même
figure de ligne de dominer ce minable et
par conséquent on les fait de ba dessous
des fonds la communauté musulmane
derrière ce dont il faudrait que
précisément la sépare est alors vous
abordez dans les trente glorieuses
énormément de de fait 2-2 moment
politique très différents les uns des
autres il y en a qui me semble très
important auquel vous réagissez encore
une fois à l'époque c'est l'été de là
canicule en 2003 l'été de là canicule en
2003 les seules images qu'on en a
conservé au fond c'est celui de
l'interview de ce ministre de la santé à
l'époque qui pris au dépourvu se
retrouve en chemisette le voilà à droite
face à thomas hugues qui présentait le
journal l époque et il est en chemise
aide parce qu'il est pendant ses
vacances et tout à coup on l'avertît on
le met au
devoir de répondre au fait qu'il ya des
jeux personnes âgées qui ce qui m'a
alors il ya une surmortalité personnes
âgées du dieu la chaleur et vous dites
vous très vite un juste après vous dites
qu'au fond c'est le moment où l'état se
reconnaît
responsable en bloc de notre vie et de
cette durée est et c'est d'autant plus
intéressant que de billets ulcos vide et
qu'on a bien vu à quel point l'état
s'était vu encore plus responsable mais
au fossat naîtrait la wii c'est à dire
que bon il y avait eu auparavant
bon des mesures qui en fait avait
restreint justement l'investissement de
l'état dans les dépenses santé publique
tant par ailleurs déjà il ya des mesures
disons 2 il ya des mesures de l'état
pour se retirer autant que possible de
l'investissement d'un sonnet public bon
ça va pas dire qu'il se retire
complètement on est d'accord là dessus
mais bon il ya ça yaya sage il ya une
politique globale fait témoin que tout
relève toujours la politique dit l'un
d'eux d'en finir avec son appli il a
pris l'état providence est bon qui
entraîne effectivement des référés
notamment des restrictions de crédits
crédits alloués aux hôpitaux et puis il
ya la canicule là dessus la canicule là
dessus est au fond la réaction de l'état
justement on a revu les cat man la même
bien sûr disons au moment du côté de 19
c'est justement au moment où on en fait
moins pour la santé les capés mois pour
la santé l'état se déclare un
responsable de notre notre extension
générale ces arbres il ya eu à procéder
un peu dans les excuses de l'état d' qui
dira oui on a pas fait attention à votre
vie quoi mais il aurait dû d'abord y
faire attention justement on avait six
ans plus dans la santé que dans les
dépenses de santé mais non il ya eu
vraiment saint-ours c'était de deux
logiques en quelque sorte les tabriz un
petit peu les formes de solidarité de
protection sociale et du même coup
devient seul défenseur le seul défenseur
de contre tous les maux qui peuvent qui
peuvent nous atteindrons qui peuvent
naître une canicule mais aussi bien la
tentative d'attentât terroriste
oui au fait que l'état dites-vous s'est
affirmé au cours de ces trente ans comme
voulant notre protecteur contre
l'insécurité quelle qu'elle soit oui
l'insécurité devenue le grand le grand
concept grands procès parce que
effectivement d'un côté l'état se
déclare simplement serviteur de la
nécessité globale il ne peut rien dire
et mondialisation il ya nécessité
économique on n'y peut rien donc il faut
il faut obéir il faut en plus obéir que
au fond on est tout le temps menacé est
aux frais de l'état instaurée cette
espèce de système de l'urgence
permanente homme gentil non permanente
ça peut ça peut aussi bien concerner le
disons les
la question des salaires bon sur l'autre
moitié les salaires d'un tout petit peu
la crise directrice qui menace mais ça
concerne aussi bien tous les tous les
périls qui peuvent nous toucher bon
christie crise climatique problèmes ce
problème sanitaire bon terrorisme bien
sûr voilà l'état a instauré cette espèce
de de règles enfin pas de règles c'est
pas ben c'est pas vraiment une règle
c'est plutôt une espèce de dirais comme
le font comme d'imaginaire structure
imaginaire structurants l'état est là
pour notre sécurité et par conséquent ça
veut dire que vont toutes les formes
disons de d'accrocs en quelque sorte au
consensus vont tomber sous ce concept de
de l'insécurité est effectivement bon
balle et gilet jaune c'est aussi de la
sécurité c'est d'insécurité comme comme
disons la canicule c'est la sécurité
voilà il ya cette espèce de de
renforcement continu d'un état dont la
fonction est de nous re protéger contre
tout ce qui nous fait peur pour cet
équidé et qui est prêt à se transformer
pour en état policier dites vous et on
l'a vu on envoie des manifestations et
en même temps à chaque fois je me dis
mais au fond est-ce que l'état n'a pas
toujours été un d'état policier c'est sa
fonction même au fond uno bien sûr bon
déjà en 60 sans en faire une paranoïa
d'ailleurs ou non mais bien sûr nommé
bon police veut dire dessin ça peut
vouloir dire des choses très différentes
bon pas police ça peut vouloir dire que
l'organisation des à l'organisation des
formes concrètes de la vie quotidienne
c'est quelque chose qui est beaucoup
plus large que simplement le fait de
donner des coups de bâton quoi mais je
dirais que yagg arias eu quand même ce
ce moment où la notion de sécurité
devient absolument central parce qu'il
n'a pas toujours été le cas bon l'état a
toujours été activement si utiliser les
méformes vieux des formes violentes pour
s'en prendre à ceux qui menacent l ordre
existant mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est quand même dans le dans le présent
qui est nouveau c'est la façon dont
toutes sortes finalement de perturbation
peut entrer dans la même catégorie de
laquelle était la catégorie de
l'institut de la sécurité l'huile c'est
vrai que voilà la grippe de hong kong en
1969 l'état très très peu réagi et on a
vu au contraire avec le co vide mais
d'après ce que vous dites dans votre
livre font ça s'est fait progressivement
mais de façon continue cet état qui dans
le consensus libéral se voulait le plus
discret possible le plus le plus
inexistant qui voulait justement lutter
contre l'êta gros gras on avait pu
connaître pendant des décennies au fond
ne cesse de se renforcer pour devenir
l'état absolument omnipotent qui versent
des salaires a absolument 80% du cheval
jeudi à chiffrer les arcs et 3% de la
population française pendant le pendant
le confinement
oui mais c'est toujours cette
logique qui sous prétexte activement de
dégraisser l'état de le rendre modeste
en fait le met dans une espèce de
rapport immédiat avec chacun chacun
d'entre nous en supprimant enfin toutes
les formes d'organisation un peu
autonome de la société au fond on se
passait de lui dans plein de domaines
notamment la sécurité sociale et on peut
de moins en moins peur oui absolue
absolument de bon il ya cette espèce de
logique qui sait que tout ce qui était
avant oui
relevé jusqu'à vendre levée d'une sorte
de solidarité sociale va désormais
relever ou bien de l'état ou bien alors
de l'assurance individuelle
et le le corps vibre pour vous c'est
quand même un événement considérable
mais comment le voyez-vous
gré je le vois que je le vois comme un
événement un événement sanitaires dont
on peut il donner bien sûr des disons
d'erreur des causes lointaines bon nous
a expliqué comment le vide était une
conséquence directe de l'exploitation
éhontée de la halle de la terre des
espèces d'animaux de la déforestation
parra commet lendemain expliqué comment
font il ya toute une logique
d'exploitation forcené du monde par
l'homme c'est-à-dire par le capitaliste
bon qui provoquait qui provoquait entre
autres locaux vides quoi mais cette mais
de là on attire l idée que bombarde du
collège et du coup ça on allait
comprendre que par conséquent une fois
le confinement terminé bataille et le
capitalisme et son volet en dessous de
cette structure du monde et son volet il
ya eu tous ses délires sur le monde
d'après quoi on avait vu que sa voix ne
marchait pas très bien ce système
existant donc pas il allait s'évanouir
mais elles n'ont après ça après ça
reprend comme avant mais comment
expliquez-vous jacques rancière on est à
la veille d'une élection présidentielle
il ya une foultitude de candidats
déclarés qui sont à peu près qui
représente pour être tout les toutes les
idées possibles et imaginables
il y en a que quelques-uns d'hôtes on se
dit qu'ils peuvent gagner et et parmi
ces quelques uns il y en a aucun
réellement considérés comme de gauche
comment l'expliquez-vous et plus
généralement on a l'impression d'une
disparition de la gauche en occident
mais leur bon je n'ai pas ne vais pas
une vision globale bon il y avait quand
même des pays où la gauche était un peu
plus dynamiques qu'en france pendant
dans certains pays mais bon on peut
penser à l'espagne au portugal pour ya
un moment où vous avez été interdit
qu'en grèce bon malheureusement ce
moment était déjà derrière nous mais bon
disons tous les pays n'ont pas subi ces
suspects de même érosion qu'en france on
voit là pour la gauche c'est un moment
donné entièrement soumise à la logique
du consensus à la logique de la
nécessité à la logique disons qu'il
fallait aller de l'avant en finir avec
toutes ces vieilleries de bons archaïque
de la sécurité sociale n'aura d'yeux du
droit du travail
voilà voilà bon je dirais que la gauche
malgré tout cette c'est largement
suicide est bon pas tout simplement en
france bien sûr on peut penser à penser
à l'angleterre qui a été en quelque
sorte un puits un modèle encore bon
si vous voulez la gauche est
connu ce moment de quasi-hégémonie d'un
parti qui s'est plus ou moins de parti
socialiste donc qui sait plus ou moins
apparaît de bon de la tradition d'un
tradition communiste d effervescence
gauchistes un peu baraka black cats
abandonné est plus ou moins c'est à
accaparer tout ça est bon at après tout
ça bien sûr avec autant d eugène des
grands systèmes de promesses après quoi
bien sûr la gauche
question a fait exactement tout le
contraire quoi voilà il ya quand même
une
succession de trahison de trahison et
trahisons encore de trahison qui ont
fait bon que la gauche est entièrement
inféodé à un système qui au départ celui
la vème république la gauche avait quand
même condamné quoi qu'elle est
entièrement soumise à la loi de la
supposée nécessité économique qui est
celle du capitalisme absolutiser je
pense qu'il ya quand même un moment tout
ça se paye comme ça se paye alors bien
sûr quand la gauche officielle trahi il
ya toujours des petites forces qui
essaye de récupérer un peu les déçus de
la trahison quoi mais il faudrait quand
même que disons y avoir un peu plus de
gred d'ouverture en quelque sorte à
avoir un peu un peu plus de dynamique
autonome pour créer une nouvelle gauche
moment là la question de la gauche
effectivement c'est que bon il n'existe
plus elle n'existe plus parce que la
gauche c'était le c'était le parti
socialiste et puis par ailleurs bon
c'est tout les gens qui essayent de
récupérer un petit peu 1% 2 % à 3 % des
dépouilles parti socialiste mais ça fait
pas une gauche ça merci jacques rancière
2 va passer toute cette émission avec
nous les trente glorieuses ça vient de
paraître aux éditions la fabrique merci
de nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]